>> My name is Steven Wasira.
I'm Minister for Agriculture, Food Security
and Cooperates from
Tanzania.
And one thing I would want to speak for a
few minutes is about
education.
And the role of education in impoverished
nations.
Actually, we from the developing countries,
particularly in Africa, are
engaged mostly in dealing with the problems
of food security and also
poverty and education.
Because we believe that the world will be
safer with more food and with
less poverty.
So education is key for this.
Educated communities can deal with the poverty
problems easily, and
they can also deal with the food security
problems easily than
uneducated populations.
So that's why we're giving a big priority
in education when it comes to
our budget in Tanzania, number one is given
to education because we
want an educated community.
So this is one area that we concentrate or
put more money into primary
education.
Put money into secondary education, and we've
managed to have more
secondary schools than we used to have, and
more students into those
schools.
But we're also trying to build up higher education.
And our fourth phase government have managed
to put up a new university
in the center part of Tanzania called Dodoma,
where when the university
is fully pledged, it will take about 40,000
students, various areas.
So this is a very important area.
But education must serve people.
And because our people are poor, then education
must be key in solving
poverty problems and food issues.